is just 150 miles from the us-mexico
border location where more than 5,000
migrants of course have their sights on
and today the Mexican government perhaps
fearing retribution from President Trump
tried to block the group from crossing
into the Mexico Guatemala frontier but
as you can see here the crowd broke down
the gates and started streaming in
police using pepper spray were able to
finally stop the rest of the caravan but
not not after many got through now the
Ingraham angle spoke exclusively tonight
with a Mexican official who told us the
following the migrants are using women
and some pregnant and children at the
front of this line in an effort to
intimidate the Mexican police so
obviously they're not going to use force
against women and children and the same
official relayed to us that there are
currently 1,000 Mexican federales at its
border with Mecca Ramallah
reinforcements are being sent in as we
speak and the police are telling the
source that many of the people inside
the caravan grew violent today injuring
six to seven Mexican police officers who
themselves have no weapons except
shields and they do have some batons if
things get bad in tear gas the official
closed his conversation with the
Ingraham angle saying following we will
not allow our country to be literally
invaded from the south it is critical
now to take a stand because if this
model is the immigration model going
forward you will see a caravan of this
size coming every week so Mexico has its
own interest in stopping these caravans
from flying through Mexico and now what
you see right here is not from the
caravan but take a look at this video
Fox News obtained this is yesterday
morning at 3:30 a.m. in Yuma Arizona now
you can see four different groups of
illegals climbing over the border wall
dropping right into the United States
and as President Trump said last night
this could be the election of the
caravan and I wanted to bring in right
now former House Speaker
Newt Gingrich new thanks for being here
tonight a big night let's start with his
Caravan issue the president said this is
this could be the election of Cavanaugh
and the caravan Cavanaugh we understand
because of fairness and due process and
men feel like they're being targeted
unfairly why is this caravan issue
important both to Mexico and of course
to the United States
well the caravan brings into vivid
attention that the Feinstein open
borders bill and the speaker Pelosi's
attitude about immigration are such big
dangers to the country the Gallup World
poll did a survey and in Latin America
and the Caribbean there 179 million
people who would like to come to the US
170 our country is 320 million right
that should be over half the population
and and what we have to confront is
exactly what that Mexican official said
if we're not prepared to stop this
Caravan how big will the next one be how
many will there be
and I think this puts Democrats frankly
in a very difficult box they don't like
to control the border they don't like to
stop immigration in fact Stacey Abrams
the Democratic candidate for governor of
Georgia said she regarded the
undocumented and the documented is equal
so she's basically saying if you get
here illegally you're part of her
majority coalition san francisco's
passed a rule that allows people here
illegally to vote so the Democrats are
now caught in that as people watch this
they're devastating images now these
images they're devastating you talk
about mobs versus jobs you're seeing
exactly the kind of mob behavior that
the Democrats have led to about two
blocks from here
new there's a homeless shelter every any
given night there are individuals
outside waiting to get in there are not
enough beds they're on the streets
they're they're destitute many of them
former military other veterans down on
their luck some with mental health
issues some not some just down on their
luck a lot of I think Americans I notice
this on radio today they give to various
organizations international
organizations that help children in need
including in Central America like food
for the poor all these great
organizations this it look
we still we have a lot of problems here
we're compassionate people we do not
want to feel like we're bad people or
horrible people because we don't want to
say anyone who wants to come in and can
come in but when you see these pictures
this is this is the the proof of what no
consequences for crossing into our
country illegally will bring they these
individuals Scott you can't even blame
them they know if they get a foothold
into the United States Newt what happens
they're carrying the Honduras right
right this is an invasion this is an act
of attacking the United States
sovereignty and in the fact right now
Mexico I want to thank the Mexican
officials and the Mexican police who are
putting their lives on the line and
getting a lot of grief from leftist
politicians we're happy to give Trump up
you know a pain in the you-know-what
over this issue well I think actually
this is the best Mexico has ever been
ever attribute that to President Trump
and secretary Pompeo but also I think to
the Mexican government being around yet
this is going to be a crisis you can't
have thousands and thousands and
thousands of people decide to break the
law and have any expectation that
civilization is going to withstand it I
want to hear from Mike Pompeo addressing
the issue of women and children being
used nude as a type of human shield
let's watch this is a large group of
people they're putting women and
children in
to use as a shield as they make their
way through this is this is an organized
effort to come through and violate the
sovereignty Mexico and so
all the weekend to support the decisions
that Mexico makes about how they're
gonna address this very serious and
important issue to their country note I
think this is a major challenge as you
said to the Democrat Party they have
embraced open borders they have welcomed
in low-skilled workers low-wage workers
as have some Republicans let's be very
clear about this over the years because
keeps wages down and a lot of businesses
are happy with that they get cheap labor
pay em cash they don't complain they
live ten in a house and it's good for
some of these construction work crews in
DC most of them speaking Spanish
hard-working people but nevertheless it
has hurt American industries from
landscaping to roofing to plumbing the
list goes on I'm telling you this is a
mistake for the Democrats to embrace
this a human I think I think the the
whole imagery that you now have these
people I mean first of all their
political activists they're not refugees
they're political activists you raised
the question last week which I keep
raising on on Twitter who's paying for
all this as you as you mentioned to me
just before the show this has gone from
three thousand to now we think five
thousand people if it takes seven
thousand dollars a person that's a
thirty five million dollar project now
who's paying for it and by the way if
it's an American group paying someone to
come and break the law that's called
aiding and abetting and that's a crime
yeah Luther lutheran church in the
Catholic Church does get about ninety
million dollars in Catholic Church
lutheran church not quite so much to
resettle migrants in the United States
so a lot of the migrants that across the
border are we can't keep them we don't
have any housing are then dropped at bus
depots well william launched an S at fox
did a great report on this yesterday and
then they're transported all across the
united states first and shelters paid
for by the catholic church lutheran
church other organizations they do get
an enormous amount of money to do this
so there's an interesting
there's an interesting like revolving
door of cash from the federal government
to these these NGOs and and 501 C 3s I
want to play a bite soundbite from
tonight the president Newt talking about
this very issue
let's watch in Mesa right now as you
know Mexico is on their southern border
their southern border
and they're fighting and they're
fighting some bad people in that group
you know you see the people come up and
you listen to the fake news back there
and you think they're all
you think they're all wonderful people
right no no you think I've serious you
think they're all wonderful people you
got some bad people in those groups you
got some tough people in those groups
and I'll tell you what this country
doesn't want them okay
yeah and I think again America is a
welcoming country we love merit-based
legal immigration true refugees a lot of
Christians in the Middle East we have
had a really hard time getting here in
Western Europeans try to get the Visa
Lottery which a lot of us want to get
away with I get do away with but Newt
he's right America they see that this
has gotten totally out of control and
it's just a question of fairness at this
point to the American worker well it's
also a question of fairness to people
whoever made the law remember we accept
more legal immigrant air than any other
country in the world
1 million those folks have all evade the
law they look over here at somebody
who's breaking the law and I think
there's a lot of resentment of why are
these people being able to break the law
no this was a Jen Psaki of course former
Obama administration official on CNN
talking about job growth speaking of the
midterms I want to play this the job
growth has been the case for six years
the job growth was actually better in
the last year of the Obama presidency
than it was in the first year of the
trump presidency so he's benefiting from
that the reality is that a good economy
is good for politics for the person in
charge it was better under Obama was
manufacturing he had a better job under
Obama I think let's start with her I
mean I think no you look I mean lowest
african-american unemployment in history
lowest Latino unemployment in history I
think we're now have the lowest general
unemployment since like 1969 it's pretty
hard not to believe that President Trump
and his policies have made a very
positive impact the only major economy
that's growing right now is the United
States none of the others are growing
and I think that we're doing something
right but I also think it comes back to
this question you know we want to be a
country that is well
to people who want to become Americans
and we want to become a country that's
welcoming to people who want to obey the
law and play by the rules and I think
this whole notion of of jobs versus mobs
is real and you've seen it here at home
with democratic mobs you're seeing
you're now trying to come up from
Guatemala with a mob and this is a very
serious question and you've had some
very strange comments and the senator
from Virginia who said though though we
ought to be punching and fighting in the
streets the former attorney general said
we're going to be kicking Republicans
Hillary saying we can't be civil you
know until we win again that's right so
there's no because they were so civil
back then
so there's all that we need to recognize
the people gotta make take take a deep
breath and ask themselves what kind of
America do you want to live in and you
really want to live in an America where
mobs are gonna come into your restaurant
to drive you out is that really what
you're comfortable with if you are then
you ought to vote Democrat I'm begging
them to do that to mean that that'll be
it bring it that's all I can say this is
President Trump tonight speaking about
what America ultimately over time turns
into if this continues let's watch they
will try to plunge our country into a
nightmare of gridlock poverty and chaos
you know that it's going to be a mess
Democrats want to raise your taxes
impose socialism on our country turn us
in to a Venezuela
turn us into another Venezuela now
notice that just overstatement oh no I
don't think so I think if you look at
what the call for example the Democrats
say they want to have universal health
care for everybody and in the California
Gavin Newsom the Democratic and for
governor says and he would give it away
to every illegal immigrant who showed up
well if you had the word went out
worldwide get to California that will
take care of your health care the sheer
cost of that would break the American
system and I think we need to understand
these are folks who don't have a clue
about the real world
but their focus on is power they want
power over you and me they want power to
define how we're allowed to behave they
know nothing about creating jobs and
nothing about economic well the
Democrats they're all up in arms because
the president trunked comments last
night about the Gion Forte well he's my
kind of politician body-slamming the
reporter they're saying well this at a
time when khashoggi was murdered at the
consulate in Turkey and the president is
sending a terrible message about freedom
of the press at a time where the press
was attacked obviously in this murder
yes and I think that the press will
always be highly sensitive you don't
notice when we talk about how dangerous
it gets how often the press are prepared
to say there was the Republican whip
Steve Scalise who was shot that it has
been Republicans recently in Nevada who
been beaten up that it was a Republican
headquarters in New York that anti-fur
destroyed you don't see much
understanding in the press about the
level of oppression from the left
Joaquin Castro who's considered one of
the shining bright lights in the
Democrat Party he's the congressman from
San Antonio he said this about Jared
Kushner let's watch let me get to the
point that I think is most disturbing
right now the reporting that Jared
Kushner may have with US intelligence
delivered a hit list an enemies list to
the Crown Prince to MBS in Saudi Arabia
and that the prince then may have acted
on that and one of the people that he
took action against as mr. Koh so gee so
Jared Kushner basically ordered
the comment is insane literally insane
the fact is Khashoggi is a public figure
everybody in Saudi Arabia knew who he
was the idea that an American had to
call and say oh gosh you may not have
noticed this guy I mean you really have
to wonder sometimes are these people
just living in some fantasy world with
no connection with reality